all right sway hi this is Wayne welcome
back
we were just talking it's been probably
been almost two years since you've been
here I think about that yeah
how everything's been for you and uh you
you traveled around the country you
stayed in L.A
um I don't know about the whole country
but I've been to Seattle
um it's about oh into Vegas yeah in
Vegas yeah and you and your
Entourage yeah you guys are uh doing
well yeah
um it's a grow it's growing a little bit
and then it shrunk back down again but
we've been pretty uh I think me and two
other girls for a little while now
and your your manager yes sir how are
things going with him uh really really
well honestly um the last time you've
seen me I was still dabbling
um but I've been off
all the bad stuffer I want to say maybe
six months now as well even clean from
drugs yeah
okay
it was really really
ugly and messy in the process but let me
go through the process it's all good
like
okay and uh tell me about working the
streets how has that been
lots of
how crazy ass experiences
um in Seattle I guess
um I was robbed at gunpoint
um right when I got down to work I
didn't get any money yet I noticed this
car was like four like super youngsters
they might have didn't even look like
they were 18 to me
um but like with a bunch of like jewelry
swagged out like yelling at me at the
window and like my gut I'm immediately
like okay let's get away from that car
you feel me and they pulled up at like
the next block and pulled around um and
the guy gets out with a [__] gun and
he's like give me a purse [__] and I
was just like like so I like ran to the
WL line in the middle of the street and
I just started going down the WL line
but it got to the point where he and two
others like chased me and it was
ridiculous because it was a red light so
all the cars were stopped you feel me
just like like it was so light outside I
couldn't freaking believe it like but he
was still coming up to me so I figured
like okay maybe if I just stole my bag
on him he'll leave there's nothing
valuable and it was little pouch with
condoms you know so what's the harm so I
threw it out and when he bounced so that
was cool but we got your condos huh you
got your condoms yeah that's about it
like he's probably pissed so that's kind
of funny but you guys have to hide your
money well yeah wherever you can right
wherever I can and I will not say where
okay I won't ask
um
you know typically a job that requires
that kind of interaction would get you
to quit
but you guys stick with it
oh yeah I'm not much of a quitter
the money is good yeah and that wasn't
that wasn't nothing like I mean that
wasn't even scary I wouldn't say like I
feared for my life like the only part
where I was like scared is because like
he didn't look like he knew how to
handle a gun
and that kind of freaked me out if that
makes sense like like if if you don't
look like you know how to shoot and you
might be somewhat like like skilled or
at least I've had practice with a gun
I'm not going to be as terrified as a
young kid fumbling you know what I mean
like that that's just dangerous more
dangerous to me anyways what is it that
draws you to this this kind of work
um you find it exciting you like the
adrenaline rush kind of like it's not so
much of an adrenaline rush like I'm a
people person like I've always been a
people person I like talking to people
getting to know people like
um so yeah
so so your your guys will just your
clients will pick you up yeah you're on
the Block
I've got I've actually got a few who
literally I feel like they treat it like
therapy sessions
I would I would see how it could be
perceived as that and so like just like
like the whole time they'll be talking
and just like unload all their [__]
[__] from that week or that day
whether it be work related wife related
kids related like and I don't really
comment or give my opinion too much but
I just kind of like listen and show that
I'm listening you know life is hard for
for everyone life is hard for everyone
the guys you know these guys are married
very often I think
uh yeah
often that that's going to be difficult
for
I mean
it is what it is honestly like
but
how does this impact your your personal
life
um
what uh this in general or the the last
question just uh in general I mean
are you
have you been in love before
yeah yeah I think I told you about that
the last time just once but that's going
to be difficult doing this kind of work
um oh I don't think I'll ever be in love
again like that was like a one time I I
met my one and I think I told you a
little bit about it last time they kind
of I lost them to mental health and that
was difficult so you have no hopes of
being in love again
um not that there's no hopes of it but
like like I just
I don't know if it was like a reality
check like I don't know it's like I I've
learned to not
um I'm not really much of like a victim
to my feelings if that makes sense like
I could I could feel things and then I
could look at it and examine it and be
like okay is this uh feeling healthy for
me is am I gonna go anywhere with this
feeling like do I really need to act on
this feeling and then I'll kind of like
took it away somewhere and just move on
you become very tough big skin doing
this
yeah my skin was semi-thick beforehand
so I guess it's pretty thick I feel like
rhino skin how do you see yourself
changing since you've been doing this
you've been doing this for how many
years now about I I had just started
when I met you oh you just started brand
new yeah okay so it's about two years
two years how do you see yourself
changing
um I've become like tougher in that
aspect yeah I've also become I I don't
want to say like humble because so many
people like like movies that you're
humble it doesn't seem humble at all you
know what I mean but like it's it's
definitely like um
mellowed me out I guess if that's the
way to think of it like I'm not as
judgmental I'm not as like like much of
a crybaby at all
right yeah you don't sweat the uh
found some small stuff there's some
stuff you get involved in with this
lifestyle because there's always
something sometimes there's always
something and every lifestyle is always
something what are you learning about
men
they're human
like
um at before I started this I was I
think I touched base on that in the
first video as well like I I used to be
very judgmental and very just like mean
I guess but I'm more like
they're going through
where do you think you'll be in five
years
um well I'm slowly Running Out of Time I
Think I'm Gonna age out here pretty soon
in the next my maybe I might have
another five years with me but I don't
think I have another 10 years in me like
there's there's a line where eventually
it's just like girl what are you doing
you're old you know
it might move on to the internet at that
point but and and drugs you know
typically help a girl do this kind of
work your your claimed from drugs you
say yeah I
I know my back hurts like I'm and
not curse sorry back hurts a lot like so
um I I do have my sorry you're gonna
have to edit that out I have my weed uh
my weed Vape thing because it helps with
my pain a lot it helps with your pain
yeah like I prefer the CBD one not the
THC one because then I get kind of
stupid
and you're friends with your other your
your partners yeah
[Laughter]
I mean obviously we have our our little
tips like and we have like our little
bumps but like we could be like in a I
don't even want to call it a fight but
we could be like like on each other's
bad side for a day but if we go out and
and somebody gives any of us a hard time
we're still going to have each other's
backs no matter what like
okay what's your biggest fear my biggest
fear
um
yeah I'm not Fearless that's for sure
but I I don't really have like a fear on
the top of my head that like overwhelms
me you know like
and your your measures
cool what kind of relationship is it I
mean do you guys is it a sexual
relationship ever
Once Upon a Time perhaps but that's
that's no no it's all business for the
most part I mean that's that's kind of
like personal you know what I mean but
at the same time it's like that's not
um that's not what they're in my life
for you know what I mean like like I
hear a bunch of girls talking about how
like [__] they're they're with people
who just want to screw them like all the
time and it's such to me they're not
doing their job correctly that's my
opinion you know what I mean I think
every pimp plays it differently yeah and
some are more business-minded and some
are more but it's like like if I'm at
work all day scary
gonna want to come home and have someone
be like all right bend over
but a lot of these guys operate as their
as your boyfriend as well
a lot of these guys will will end up
playing the role of a boyfriend
I don't see that the person I'm with
doing that now right that's what I'm
saying it's very um he's he's tough you
feel me he's very tough and harder and
he keeps me at the best version of
myself if that makes sense like no
[__] no Tom Fuller you know [__]
like but at the same time is like like
we can have fun and we go do fun stuff
and we laugh and like we watch movies
and we have a normal life like when we
were leaving Seattle uh the first time a
few months ago he knows I love love love
love swimming so we went to Green Lake
and like as a surprise after the shift
and I got to go swimming in the lake
with all the Ducks and it was like the
best day ever that was nice that's nice
what's your greatest strength
my greatest strength
um is probably being able to keep cool
in like not cool situations like not
showing on my face that I'm like like
intimidated or scared or that I'm have
anxiety like like in certain situations
where maybe there's other people trying
to like like spook me or start on me or
whatever like I can just kind of like
look straight and keep walking and keep
my face calm even though behind closed
doors it might be like shaking a little
bit but like I could definitely keep it
together like in public yeah what is
your favorite kind of trick
ah I don't know if I have a favorite
kind but there is like definitely two
kinds that are cool like
um like I like the foreigners who are
gonna spend a bunch of money and then I
come back like I had a Asian guy who had
never been here before and he liked me
because I think I was wearing a like a
school girl skirt or something and I
reminded him of like anime or something
like that so like the first he did like
I think 15 or 20 minute date he gave me
300 bucks that was nice but like um the
next day after that he called me back
with 700 for like the same amount of
time so I was like cool call me when
you're in America next time sometimes
these guys kind of get attached to you a
little bit right here and there I've had
I have had a couple instances where I
did have to draw the line and I I
respectfully uh discontinued the the
service just because it was in my best
interest you know yeah you felt it was
dangerous not dangerous it's just like
like people become infatuated and it's
not if it's not helping me progress like
like in fact if they want to keep paying
me more and more that's cool but then
they get to the point where they think I
should be their girl instead and they
don't need to be my client anymore and
at that point it's like why do I even
talk to you block move on you know like
and emotionally what is this work doing
to you does it affect you
I'm I'm a weird one when it comes to
emotions like I I think it affects me
but I do believe it's affecting me
positively if that makes sense in what
way
just like helping like I don't get hung
up on the small stuff like I'm not like
a feeling this person where it's like
like it's very difficult to hurt my
feelings like very very difficult like I
I just kind of let whatever the hell
anyone has to say just kind of roll off
because if it's not like my truth or
what I believe for myself it's not going
to affect me you know you you and your
wifey stay where you have an apartment
you have motels hotels
we have a little like apartment thing a
little little thingy Airbnb
or something like that yeah
do you believe in karma absolutely yes
how's your car how's your karma I think
my karma is pretty good I think I'm rich
in karma and I got a fat savings account
too that's nice
um no I I I've always believed in like
the Golden Rule but
um I was raised by two very very very
caring and just beautiful people you
know so it's like wherever I I see
anybody who needs an area that I'm in
the place to help if that makes sense I
I will you know like I never almost
never will deny someone a cigarette as
long as I have some I'll share one I'll
give my last cigarette right away it's
no big deal you know what I mean um if I
got extra food I share with whoever like
it's not you know so you say you have a
nice bank account is that oh no I was
referring to my my karma your karma
Adventure your actual bank account is
nice so you're giving all your money to
your to your manager
and he takes care of you absolutely so
yeah he handles the money
I'm terrible with money so that's
honestly that's that's what I've learned
is all these girls that are on the
streets yeah are all they seem to be all
terrible with money I'm sure there's
there's exceptions
there's still like like if I it's not
like I don't have access to it you feel
me like it's like I I never want for
anything like if there's something I
want or need I I voice it and I receive
it you know and most of the times I
don't even have to voice it most of the
time it's just observed that it's
something I need and I'm surprised with
it so that's cool but what is the
hardest part of this lifestyle for you
um
does everybody with different
personalities like in a small house
setting just like just being able to be
cool with each other you know what I
mean it's like it's not I don't know
it's that's the hardest part but it's
like also it's like you have to be a big
person you know what I mean you have to
like let Petty issues not be a big deal
and and know that we're all like in this
together you feel me and like we're in a
family and just be cool
um
it's almost like a polygamous
relationship isn't it
yeah I could see that in a sense there's
definitely uh similarities however like
lots of differences as well
I want to say a polygamous relationship
as much as like a um what's the other
one called like a like a Triad or a
polyamorous yeah yeah and we're probably
I guess polyamorous would be more I
don't know
your intuition is is become heightened
from doing this kind of stuff yeah
my intuition was already pretty pretty
strong but like I've gotten to the point
where I know if a car is like a waste of
time or not what cues do you see I I
really I couldn't tell you I don't know
because it's always different but
something about like I'll look at a
certain vehicle and I will just keep
walking and like my wife would be like
hey they're trying to talk to you so
just to humor them I'll be like okay
I'll go talk to him and just like I said
it'll end up being a waste of time and a
waste of money and I'll keep walking
they're like how did you know and I'm
like I don't know man I just know like
what lessons are you learning from doing
this
lessons in my learning I mean I don't
know if it's a lesson I'm learning but
like I've become very very loyal like if
I wasn't already loyal I've become
very exceedingly well
um and that was a scary thing for me
before because it's like I had never
been
with somebody who who actually deserves
that loyalty like on a real level you
feel me like or who actually deserved me
to to fully one thousand percent trust
them like the only man who I've trusted
like that beforehand has been my father
like you know so it had been since 2008
when my dad passed away that I since I
had actually trusted a man and given
them everything and and just put my all
into the situation you had a good
relationship with your father oh my God
yeah I was my best friend what would
your dad say if he saw you today
honestly and this is the same the same
thing my mom's on honestly he would look
at me and he'd be like look if you're
safe and if you're happy cool are you
safe and are you happy yeah
all right sweet great seeing you again
thank you so much I'm glad you're you're
healthy and happy yeah
I wish you you and your entourage a lot
of luck thank you